ELLIE POWERS: Hi, everybody.
I'm Ellie Powers, and I'm
a Product Manager here
on the Google Play team.
And as Shannon mentioned,
what I'm here to talk about
is what's happening in
Android development in 2016.
It's kind of amazing
to even say that.
Because we talk about
the Android platform,
and it feels so immediate to me.
I've been at Google almost
five years, and when I joined,
that platform was very new.
It's come a huge way--
a very, very long way.
And I'm excited today
to share with you some
of the things that we're
most excited about,
and some of the things
that we think that you need
to know about as
developers in order
to make the best apps possible.
So Android development is a lot
more sophisticated this year
than it was back in the past.
And that's really important.
And it's happening because users
have much higher expectations
than ever.
Users want apps
that are innovative,
that are highly functional,
that are beautiful,
and take advantage of all
the latest technologies.
Now as a developer, you want
to give them all of that.
You want to make those
great user experiences.
But you want to have the least
amount of hassle possible.
Totally.
And that's why you need more
sophisticated tools that are
going to bring you more power.
So today, I'm going to talk
about four different areas
of Android development.
First, we're going to talk
about the latest Android
dessert, Nougat.
It's sticky, it's sweet, and it
might get stuck in your teeth.
And it's got a lot
of great new features
that users are going to love.
We're going to
talk about what you
need to know as a developer.
Second, we're going
to talk about what's
new with Material Design.
It launched a
couple of years ago,
and there are some new things
that you should know about.
Third, we're going to
talk about Android Studio.
That's another product that's
been progressing a lot.
So we're going to
talk about how that
can help you build better apps.
And finally, we had a huge
announcement this year
at Google I/O about Firebase.
Firebase means a lot more this
year than it did last year.
And we're going to go
through a lot of the features
that it offers.
It's all about building
and growing your apps
cross-platform, so we're going
to talk a little bit more
about how that can help
you with your overall app
business-- including
Android, but also beyond it.
So first, let's talk
about Android Nougat.
Has anyone here tried
Android Nougat so far?
Got a build on one
of your devices?
That's great.
So you may have a
favorite feature,
but I'm going to tell
you a few of mine.
One of my favorite
things about it
is the improved battery life.
And another one is, when
you upgrade to a new version
and install an
update, it doesn't
need to go back and optimize
all your apps anymore.
That's one of my
favorite things,
especially because I have
like 150 apps on my phone.
So those are features
that are great for users.
And now we're going to walk
through the things that
are most important to
know about as a developer.
So first up is multi-window.
What this means is a user can
use their phone or tablet,
or even TV, to do more than
one thing at the same time.
Now this can be
great for users who
like to do things
like maybe watching
a video of the cooking
recipe demonstrating how
to make an item while looking
at the recipe or the shopping
list in another screen.
So you can look at those two
activities at the same time.
Maybe, if you're like me, when
you're doing your work email,
you also like to watch cat
videos at the same time.
And so multi-window
will help you do that.
We find that mutli-window works
especially well with devices
that have much larger screens.
I use it on my Nexus 6P and
find it works pretty well there.
And it's really easy
to have this work.
It'll start working on your
apps automatically by default.
You don't actually
have to do anything.
But in order to make
sure it works well,
you'll probably want to test
out your apps with Nougat
in the multi-window
mode, and just
make sure that everything is
working well and looking good.
And the reason this
works so easily
is that Android apps
and their layouts
are so good at adjusting
anyway to take advantage
of different screen
sizes, right?
If you open your app on
a different size device,
it'll adjust automatically.
And so with multi-window,
a similar thing
is happening here.
Now after you've tested it, if
you want to make a few tweaks,
there are certain parameters
that you can change-- things
like default or minimum
sizing, if you want to make
sure it works exactly right.
So next up, notifications.
Marshmallow had a big
notifications overhaul.
And in Nougat, we still
weren't satisfied,
so we decided to
do even more stuff.
We're going to talk through a
few of the important changes.
So first up, there's new
templates for notifications.
Another really
important thing is
there is an attribution marker.
You can see up here
there's a green icon,
and it says Hangouts.
This way, a user can
be sure exactly which
app sent that notification.
Also, we offer
bundled notifications.
I use this all the time because
I get a lot of Gmail messages.
And so with bundled
notifications,
they all come
together as one group,
so it's easier for the user
to manage those notifications.
But my favorite feature
with notifications in Nougat
is actually these quick actions.
If you look at the
screenshot in the right, what
you can see here are these
quick action buttons.
So if you get a message,
you don't actually
have to open the
app to reply to it.
For example, here, I could
just click on the Reply
button or the Archive button.
And so when I find
that I'm running
from meeting to meeting,
it's really easy for me
to send quick messages
to my colleagues
or friends and family as
I'm going through my day.
So does anyone here in this
room speak multiple languages?
Yeah.
I had a feeling that this
would be a big hit in Europe.
I speak one language pretty
well, and then two languages
pretty badly.
And so we think, in
Europe, this is going
to be a pretty popular feature.
So the idea is that many people
don't speak just one language.
They speak more.
And so what we
allow the user to do
is to specify their different
languages that they speak
and put them in their
order of preference.
So when a user tries
to open an app,
Android will try to load
the app in the user's
first-choice language.
If that app translation isn't
available in that language,
they'll load the second choice,
the third choice, and so on.
So for example, in this
case, with this screen here,
it would first try to
open the app in English.
If that didn't work,
it would try Spanish.
And then, as a last resort,
it would try French.
So as a developer, there
shouldn't be anything
that you have to do
to make this work.
It should just
work automatically.
But we think that you'll like
knowing that this is available,
and that this will help users
be able to make sure they're
seeing your app in the right
language that's right for them.
So in Marshmallow,
we talked last year
about a huge overhaul to
the permissions platform.
Permissions are now
real-time as of Marshmallow.
But there were a
couple of things
that we wanted to tweak to
make them work even better.
So has anyone ever had
to ask for the permission
to access a user's
internal storage,
and it used to pop up
a message about, hey,
can I access your photos and
this and that and a bunch
of different things?
We had a lot of feedback from
developers that, sometimes,
they would only need to
access one of these things,
and gaining access to
all of these things
was concerning to users.
And we thought that that was
absolutely great feedback.
So what we've done is
we've broken it down so
that, as a developer, rather
than requesting access
to all of the storage,
you can request access
to a specific folder.
So for example, in this case,
maybe this is a photo app.
And so it's actually asking
to access just the Pictures
folder.
And so this means that a user
understands a lot better why
what you're requesting
is necessary,
and also, you're not gaining
access to other files
that you may not need
to have access to.
So does anyone here in
this room work on 3D games?
Yeah, a couple of folks.
That's really cool.
So Vulkan is a new technology.
It's a low-level, low-overhead
and cross-platform 3D API.
And it's also available
in Android Nougat as well.
So this is a really
great technology
that helps if you're
trying to write
games that work cross-platform.
It works a lot more
similarly across
these different platforms.
And also, if you use a game
engine, a lot of engines
are supporting it already,
or have a platform
to be able to support
Vulkan in the future.
So what this means now,
with Vulkan being supported
in Nougat, is, if
you are using Vulkan,
it'll start to work really well
on these devices right away.
So that was Android Nougat.
And now we're going to move
on and talk about what's
new in Material Design.
So first of all,
how many apps here
are using Material
Design already?
A good number of folks.
So if you're using
Material Design,
you're actually in
really good company.
We noticed recently that we
have basically a million apps
on the Play Store that
are using Material Design.
And if you haven't heard of
it, what Material Design is
is a set of principles
that govern how apps look,
how they move, how they feel.
And it's this set
of design principles
that covers things like
tactile surfaces, rich imagery,
bold colors, and my favorite,
which is meaningful motion.
And why Material Design
is important for you
as a developer is that,
when a person uses
your app for the first
time, you want them
to know how it works, right?
And if you're already using
this Material Design framework
that users understand, it
will be more intuitive to them
to understand how to get
started with your app.
You'll be less likely
to have a person who
gets confused or lost and
doesn't know how to do it.
And so if you're looking
to reach the over 1.4
billion Android
users that are active
today, using Material
Design can be
a critical part of
the process in order
to make sure that they're going
to know how to get started
immediately and stay engaged.
So we'll talk about a couple
examples of developers
here in Europe that are
using Material Design.
So first up is Bring!
from Switzerland.
And they implemented
Material Design.
Now if you haven't
used the Bring! app,
it's all about being able to
manage multiple shopping lists.
And it does things
like informing you
about what items still
need to go in your cart.
You can also share
your shopping list.
So if you have a roommate or
spouse who's at the store,
you can alert them
at the last minute
if there's something that
they need to pick up for you.
So Bring! has used
Material Design
to implement a
consistent toolbar
across the different
screens in their app.
It allows them to keep
their most popular features
accessible wherever you go.
And so they've managed
to fit in search, the nav
drawer, imagery,
and an invite button
on this toolbar that's
visible throughout their app.
And they were pretty
happy with how
this went because,
when they launched it,
they saw that they had a 66%
increase in session times
in the six months following the
launch of the Material Design
revamp.
And they also managed
to get showcased
on the materialup blog as well.
Fabulous is another app.
This one's based in Paris.
And it's a science-based
app that encourages users
to adopt a healthy lifestyle.
And it does this by
developing a personalized
step-by-step program
for each user.
And so in this layout,
we can see that they're
using cards as well.
But in this case,
they're using this
to help a user organize
their habits and their goals.
And when you tap on these
cards, they elevate.
And with the help
of icons, they make
it really easy for the user to
see exactly what they're doing,
and to understand every
action that they're taking.
It's a very clear
layout, and users
have responded really well.
So since they did their
Material redesign in 2015,
they've actually had a tenfold
increase in daily downloads.
So they've been really happy
with this result as well.
So let's talk about what's new
with Material Design this year.
When we first introduced
it, we had some devices
that were able to support a
lot of advanced, complicated
things.
But some devices weren't.
The great news is that, in
2016, on average, devices
are just so much more
powerful than they were when
Material was first announced.
So we're really encouraging
developers this year
who want to really
set themselves apart
from a design standpoint to
look at the use of motion.
With the higher-end devices, you
can support a lot more motion
than you could with lower-end
devices a couple of years ago.
So motion is really powerful
because, not only can it
be fun, can it be
amusing, can it really
bring charm and
character to your brand,
but it's also a real
usability feature.
Using motion in
your app can help
a user understand as
they transition from one
screen in your app to the next.
Really helps understand
the transitions.
And as I mentioned, it's also
a great way to bring in fun,
delight, and even
make your users laugh.
So that was what's new with
Material Design in 2016.
And now the question is,
how do I make this happen?
If I want to support the
latest Nougat features,
bring a great design, and
build a wonderful app that's
really going to get
noticed, how do I do it?
And let's talk about
Android Studio for that.
So is anyone here using
Android Studio today?
Is anyone not using
Android Studio?
Cool.
Every year, we're seeing
more and more people
using the Studio.
And the reason
for that, we hope,
is that we wanted to build
a purpose-focused IDE.
We wanted to have
something that really
was tuned for the languages that
Android development is based on
and really felt native
to the Android platform.
And we've really been
shocked and humbled
by the amount of momentum
we've seen on the Android
Studio of adoption so far.
So those of you who said
you're using Android Studio,
you're in very good company.
If we look at the top 125
apps and games on Play,
actually 92% of them are
using Android Studio.
That's been great to see.
And of course, millions of
developers all over the world
are using Android
Studio as well.
So for those of you who maybe
didn't know Android Studio as
well, let's take a little
bit of time to talk about it,
and talk about what was
new in the past year.
So at the beginning of the year,
we launched Android Studio 2.0.
The major focus here was speed.
That was a real key
piece of feedback
we had from developers.
They said, make it faster
if you do nothing else.
Came back time and time again.
So we introduced something
called Instant Run.
Now the idea here is that
you can do swaps of code
in real-time when you
go to run your app.
There's not a lot of waiting.
And it can push code and
resources directly into the app
while it's running
on your computer.
And this also included not
just Instant Run but also
major improvements
to the emulators.
It included a new emulator
UI, a GPU profiler view,
search deep-linking, creation
and building of test cases.
We'll talk about those
things a little bit later.
And then, in 2.1, we built
that release side-by-side
with the team working on Nougat.
So this is all about
supporting Android Nougat
so we have support for
the new features and APIs,
new Nougat emulators to
test on, Jack compiler
support so that you
can try N's Java 8
support, and important
stability enhancements.
That was something else we heard
from you is that every time we
need to update it,
we need to make
sure it's just
really high-quality,
production-grade stuff.
And then, in 2.1, we also
made an additional investment
into Instant Run.
We moved the decks
in-process, and that
was a huge accelerator, allowing
Instant Run to get even faster
than previous incarnations.
So of course, now we're
looking at Android Studio 2.2.
The main focuses there are
speed, smarts, and support
for Nougat.
And so we also have a ton
of updates in this release--
everything from Firebase
integration to enhanced support
from C .
So I'm going to highlight a
few things that you should know
about in this latest release.
So as a developer, one of the
best feelings in the world
is being in the flow.
You know, you finally
sort of load up
in your brain all of
the code that's running.
You're working on it.
And the last thing you
want is to get disrupted,
to break that flow when you're
waiting for your app to build
and run on your machine.
So that's why we
introduced Instant Run.
And we've made progressive
improvements since its launch.
You can see a lot of the
updates here into the speed.
And that's really been getting
a lot of good feedback.
And we're going to keep
trying to work on that
and improving it even further.
We've also seen a big
development in the Android
ecosystem around C .
When we first started
working on Android,
we thought that native
code was something that
was going to be pretty rare.
And it was.
And then, as Android's
evolved, we've
actually seen more
and more developers
using C for more
and more reasons.
Initially, it would just be
for things like maybe physics
simulations, but
we've seen over time
that more and more
types of apps and games
are using native code.
So we've realized we need to
enhance the support for it
a lot more.
So you can now actually do a
whole bunch of more things in C
.
And let's walk
through a few of them.
So we've already supported
editing and debugging
of native code.
But with 2.2, we're bringing
you IntelliJ 2016.1.
This includes a lot of
IntelliJ enhancements
to C from the Sea
Lion 2016.1 release.
And now you can also just run
the app like any normal Android
app using the Run dialog.
It's much more integrated
into the overall Build and Run
experience.
So now this is also
integrated with the debugger
so that you can set the
breakpoint, then run the app,
and the debugger will break
at the right place executing
the code on your machine.
It's just a much more
integrated, well-run test,
run, and build cycle
on your machine.
So next, I'd also want to
tell you a little bit more
about the C debugger
enhancements.
So in 2.2, you no longer have
to select explicitly whether you
want a C , a Java,
or a hybrid debugger.
You can just use
Auto, and then the IDE
will automatically
select the right debugger
for what you're trying to do.
And if you're debugging
code in N and above,
you can actually just use one
debugger for both of these,
thanks to our
Java-aware C debugger.
So let's talk about design.
We talked a little
bit earlier about
how users respond
so well when you've
made your app look great.
And Android Studio
has introduced
a couple of new features to
really help you improve this.
So first of all,
the Layout Editor.
It's a new user
interface designer.
It helps you quickly design
the layouts in your app
and a much more visual way,
a much more interactive way.
And so you don't have to
go back and forth so much
between coding and previews.
We also have some new features.
Here you can see
the Blueprint Mode.
It's really powerful.
And we have a new
Properties panel also
over there, which
allows you to quickly
edit the layouts and
the widgets faster.
We've also introduced
a new type of layout.
It's called constraint layout.
Previously, we'd see
a lot of developers,
when they wanted to achieve
a very precise layout,
they end up nesting a bunch
of different layout types
inside of each other.
It would be very hard
to debug, very clunky.
We've all probably
spent a few hours
fiddling with these things,
wondering why it never
quite lines up right.
And so what we've done
with constraint layout
is it gives you a lot
more powerful language
to express complex
UIs, but you don't
have to do this horrible
layout nesting anymore.
So we think this will really
simplify your experience
for creating and
managing your apps.
And together with
the Layout Editor,
you'll be able to have a much
more powerful and simple way
of modifying your layouts.
Now if you do have
a tricky layout
issue that you can't
really figure out,
we also have something
called Layout Inspector.
Now the idea here is that
you can debug a snapshot
of your app's layout.
You can have it running
on your Android emulator,
on your computer, or
on your Android device.
And it'll give you tools to
inspect the view hierarchy.
And you can look at different
corresponding attributes
to find and fix the layout
issues that you couldn't
debug a little bit more easily.
So another thing that a lot
of developers are trying to do
is to get more efficient
with their apps--
not just in how they
build them, but also
in the binaries that are
delivered to users' devices.
So the tool that you
have that's best for this
is called the APK Analyzer.
It's really designed
to help you keep
your app small and efficient.
And for those of you
who are building apps
for emerging markets--
places like India, Brazil,
and Indonesia-- this
becomes even more critical,
as users don't have
a ton of storage,
and also have limited
network connectivity.
We'll give you a little
bit more information
about that in the Building
for Billions exercise.
So APK Inspector can
help you figure out
which of the different
files in your APK
are taking up a lot of space.
It can also help you do things
like avoiding the 64K reference
method limit issues
with your dex files.
It can help you diagnose
ProGuard config issues
and inspect complex
resources files.
It's really to help you analyze
every aspect of your APK
and get rid of the bloat.
Now one of the
other things to note
is that the APK Analyzer
actually shows you file size
in a couple of different ways.
First of all, you can
see the raw file size.
But actually, you can
also see the download size
of various components
in your APK.
And what is the
difference between those?
Well, the download size is
actually the estimated size
that users would actually need
to download when the APK is
served from Google Play.
And that can actually be
different from the raw file
size.
So this information
should really
help you prioritize where to
focus your efforts in reducing
app size and make sure that
you're doing the highest
return on investment there.
So let's move on and talk
about testing, right?
Testing is really critical.
The most basic thing
that users want
is they want your
app to work well.
And so you know, writing UI
tests can be really tedious.
And a lot of developers
have this as their least
favorite thing to do.
And we wanted to
make that easier,
because testing is so
critical and so important
when you're trying to get a
high star rating on Google Play,
or trying to create
an app that users love
and will want to come back to.
So we created
something really new.
We created something called
the Record Espresso Test
UI in Android Studio.
So here's what you can do.
It's just as easy
as using your app.
You can run your app, and then
Android Studio will actually
capture all of your
UI interactions,
and it'll convert them into a
fully reusable Espresso test.
And then you can run this test
locally with Android Studio,
maybe using the emulator.
Or you can actually run
it against Firebase Test
Lab, which we'll talk
about a little bit later.
And so if you want
to use the recorder,
you can just go to
the Run menu, and then
select the Record
Espresso Test function.
So if you have been sort of
procrastinating and putting off
writing any tests because it's
a big pain-- which it is--
I would highly encourage
you to use the Espresso Test
Recorder to get started.
If you just record a couple
of simple tests for the most
common flows in your app, that
can pay off hugely when you're
trying to make sure you
don't have any regressions
of functionality.
Also core to testing is having
a great local test solution.
An emulator, right?
And the Android
emulator didn't used
to be as fast as
we wanted it to be.
And so users would
tell me-- developers
would tell me that they
spend a ton of time and money
trying to source a whole
wide range of devices.
When I'd go to visit
developers in their offices,
they would show me a gigantic
drawer, or maybe even
a full closet full of all
of the Android devices
that they had to buy.
Probably a lot of you have
one of those closets as well.
So we've wanted to try to make
this unnecessary, or at least
a lot less necessary.
So what we've been
doing is focusing
on improving the emulator.
One of the biggest
concerns there was speed.
We've now improved the
emulator so it's actually
faster than a physical device.
We're really excited about that.
And we hope that being able
to use more of your testing
on emulators will
mean that you don't
have to spend as
much time and money
managing your gigantic
drawer of Android devices.
And you can spend more
of your time doing
some of the funner parts.
Finally, Android Studio
is also the easiest way
to integrate the suite
of Firebase tools
that I'm about to talk about.
We want to make it easier
for you to add services
like analytics, authentication,
notifications, and AdMob,
with just a couple of
clicks in Android Studio.
So we've made that a lot easier.
OK, so I started talking a
little bit about Firebase
and how it integrates
with Android Studio.
But let's talk about
actually what Firebase is.
So Firebase was a
company that Google
acquired a couple of years ago.
And when we acquired
them, they were actually
mostly like backend services.
And now at Google
I/O this year, we're
really excited to announce
that Firebase is a lot more
than that.
Firebase is actually a
whole suite of technologies.
We've tried to
bundle together all
of the most important
Google Developer services
and created one
cross-platform suite of tools.
It used to be if
you wanted to use
a bunch of different developer
services from Google,
you had to go to a bunch
of different places--
multiple SDKs, multiple
websites of documentation.
It was more complicated
than we wanted.
But with Firebase,
we've combined
a bunch of the different
components together--
you know, single
SDKs, centralized hubs
of documentation, et cetera.
So it's a lot easier for
you as a developer to use
multiple Google tools together.
And one key point to note.
Firebase is cross-platform.
It will work
fantastic on Android.
But we know all of
you want to support
your app on multiple
platforms as well,
and so Firebase
also works on iOS.
So let's talk about
the thing that
brings together all
the different Firebase
tools-- analytics.
It's at the core.
Everything you want
to do as a developer,
you also want to measure and
see how it impacts users.
So Firebase Analytics product
is great about giving you
information about how users
behave, and also where they're
coming from when they
go into your app.
We built it from scratch
to support app developers
cross-platform.
And a lot of people
ask us, well,
how is it different
from Google Analytics?
And I think the
key thing to know
about it is it was built
by the same team that
built Google Analytics.
Firebase Analytics is super
optimized for mobile apps.
And we think it's a
great place to get
started if you haven't
picked a solution already,
or if you're looking at
getting a better analytics
product for apps and games.
So here's an example of what
Firebase Analytics can look
like with a particular game.
And then one of the
things we wanted
to do with Firebase
Analytics is to make sure
that, out of the box, you get
as much information as possible,
so you don't have to spend
a bunch of time duplicating
the sorts of things that every
developer would want to have.
So it's a great way to
look at, for example,
the usage from your app.
You can also do
experiments with analytics.
And in a lot of cases, you won't
even need to do any coding.
So for those of you who work
at smaller companies, you know,
it's really great to set
these sorts of things
up so that people like product
managers and marketing folks
can run experiments or get
data without always having
to ask engineering teams to go
and add more code to the app.
So that was analytics.
And now we're going
to zoom in on a couple
of different parts
of the Firebase suite
to understand more about that.
And we'll start with Develop.
I've listed a bunch of
the different technologies
here that Firebase offers.
Unfortunately, I
don't have the time
to talk about them all
today, so we're going
to focus on a couple of things.
First up is authentication.
One of the most common
things developers
want users to do in their app
is to sign in, because that way,
you can offer the user a
personalized experience
that evolves with them as
they keep using your app.
And so Firebase
authentication gives you
a bunch of different options.
It supports email and password
login; it supports Google,
Facebook, Twitter,
and GitHub sign-in;
and if you already have
an existing system,
it can integrate with those
existing user accounts.
And Firebase authentication
has an open-source library.
And it's fully integrated
with other Firebase features
as well.
So just as an example, if you
use Firebase authentication,
you can also use it
to control access
to user data in the
real-time database.
So Firebase Cloud Messaging,
which was formerly
known as Google Cloud
Messaging, is a cross-platform
messaging solution that
lets you deliver messages
to users in a reliable
way, with no cost,
and also trying to minimize
impact on users' battery life.
Firebase Test Lab for
Android is a great way
to catch bugs before you
ship your code to users.
We talked about
this a little bit
before, how you can record
tests on Android Studio.
And Firebase Test Lab,
it's really important
to know that's actually
running your tests
on real, physical devices that
are located in an data center
at Google.
Now if you want to get started
with our Firebase Test Lab,
actually, the best
way to do it is
to go into the Google
Play Developer Console.
We have something in there
called the pre-launch report,
which we're actually going
to hear a little bit more
about later.
We definitely encourage you
to try the pre-launch report
in the Developer
Console, and to be
able to use it with all of
your alpha and beta apps.
Now while you may try to catch
most of your issues and bugs
through testing
before the launch,
we all know that
we're not always
100% effective in this, right?
So Firebase Crash
Reporting is a great way
to find out about issues that
are occurring in the field
after your launch.
So whenever an app crashes,
it's reported by Firebase Crash,
and the developer can
review these in a report.
Again, this also
works cross-platform,
so you can use it
across all of your apps.
So that was developing an app.
And now let's talk about some
of the technologies to help
grow an app.
First up is dynamic links.
I was just talking to a
developer about this yesterday.
A lot of us want to be able
to provide a single link that
works cross-platform, and also
to be able to deep link someone
to a page within an app,
even if that user had
to go through the install flow.
And this is really helpful.
These links can work
across different platforms.
And they do carry the
URL state after the user
has completed the install.
And also, they're integrated
with Firebase Analytics,
so you can also see the
activity that's coming in
through these dynamic links.
And app indexing.
This is something we launched
a couple of years ago.
It's integrated with
Firebase as well.
And this is a great way
to be able to take content
for your app and service it
to users within Google Search.
And also, as users
interact with your app,
it can also boost your search
ranking in Google Search.
It also provides things like
autocomplete in the search bar,
bringing users into the
content for your app
really easily and directly.
And notifications.
So Firebase Notifications
is a free service.
A lot of developers ask me,
how can I manage these better?
And this is a good
solution for it.
It gives a simple UI for
generating notifications.
A lot of the time, you don't
even need to write code.
You can just use the Firebase
Notifications console.
So again, this is
a great way where,
if you have multiple
people working on your app,
even folks who don't do
coding on a daily basis
can still go in and set
up new notifications.
So in the client for
Android, no coding
is needed for background
notifications.
And if you want to
do notifications
on iOS or foreground
notifications,
there's just a little bit
of coding required there.
Also, you can
see-- you know, you
want to be really
sure as a developer
that you're not sending
too many notifications
or having users feel like
they're getting spammed.
So you can actually
look at analytics
to be able to track conversion
rates on these notifications,
so you can understand
which ones are effective
and which ones might
not be as welcome.
So that's how to build
and grow your app.
Finally, the most important
part, perhaps, earning money.
So AdMob is a popular way
to be able to monetize
your mobile apps
through advertising.
And now it's been
brought together
in the same suite of tools
to make it a lot easier
to integrate with in Firebase.
There's a number of
different ad formats
if you haven't tried AdMob yet.
We have video ads.
We have native ads.
We have interstitial ads.
And we're seeing over one
million apps using AdMob today.
And again, it's fully
integrated with Firebase.
But if you're already
using AdMob already,
you can still start using
it without having to adjust
or mess up your existing
AdMob configuration.
OK, so that was my talk.
Today, we talked about
what's new in Android
development in 2016.
First, we talked about Nougat.
We talked about our latest
version of the Android release.
We talked about improvements
to the user experience-- things
like multi-window, multiple
languages, notifications,
and a couple of tweaks
to the permissions flow.
Next, we talked about
Material Design.
It's very quickly
becoming the default
in the user expectation.
We have over a million
apps using it today.
And actually, the
thing we want to focus
on this year, if you're thinking
of refining your Material
Design implementation,
is talking
about bringing in more motion,
to make your app easier
to use, and also to
make it a lot more fun
and add personality.
Third, we talked
about Android Studio.
We have Instant Run.
It's a lot faster to use.
But we also have
important new features
around the areas of design--
things like the new constraint
layout to help you simplify
complex layouts, and also
the emulator to help you do
testing a lot more quickly.
So that's what we learned
about in Android development.
But I think our biggest
announcement for this year
was Firebase.
This cross-platform
suite of tools
is really powerful to help
you build great Android
apps, and also great iOS apps.
I think a lot of
developers are trying
to manage multiple apps
across multiple platforms.
And with Firebase,
it's a lot simpler
to get all of the best things
that you want from Google
with a lot less of the hassle.
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]